every job as a one co-worker everyone
avoids like the plague well it turns out
that working in Hollywood is just like
any other job and some celebrities have
earned a serious reputation among their
co-stars so much so that other actors
don't ever want to work with them again
let's take a look at some of the most
infamous co-star beefs and how they got
started Julia Roberts versus Nick Nolte
co-stars in the 1994 rom-com I love
trouble
Robertson notes he did a mesh well
on-screen or off reportedly the constant
quarreling got so bad but director Joel
Shire resorted to filming some of their
scenes separately to keep them apart as
much as possible you have zero chance of
scoring here trust me Mitch Vil while
shooting Roberts told the New York Times
that Nolte was completely disgusting and
seems to go out of his way to repel
people Nolte later shot back it's not
nice to call someone disgusting but
she's not a nice person everyone knows
that James Franco vs. Tyrese Gibson much
of the 2006 military drama Annapolis
centers around a plan the boxing
tournament for the US Naval Academy
finish this
is not worthy of this Academy good not
quitting but Franco took his method
acting way too far
according to co-star Tyrese Gibson
Franco actually landed punches during
rehearsal Gibson told Al the dude was
full-on hitting me I was always like
James lighten up man we're just
practicing
he never lightened up Franco denies ever
hitting Gibson but admitted to GQ
I was probably a jerk but the admission
wasn't good enough for Gibson who told
Playboy in 2007 I never want to work
with him again and I'm sure he feels the
same way it felt very personal it was
dub shannen doherty vs. everyone the
notoriously difficult shannen doherty
reportedly nearly came to blows whether
Beverly Hills 90210 castmate Jennie
Garth fighting became so bad that fellow
902 1 ovett Tori Spelling revealed to
lifetime in 2015 as she even got her
father Aaron Spelling who produced the
show to fire Doherty then four years
later Doherty and custom 8 Alyssa Milano
beefed on the set of another Aaron
Spelling production charmed according to
Milano there were definitely some rough
days it was very much sort of like high
school over a decade has passed since
Dougherty's departure from Charmed and
it seems sheer Milano have finally
buried the hatchet
when Doherty was diagnosed with breast
cancer in 2016 Elano said I told her my
concern and how everyone was on her side
and and we're all supporting her and and
she was very appreciative that I reached
out Richard Gere vs. Sylvester Stallone
for years there's been an apparent
behind-the-scenes feud between Gere and
Stallone Stallone finally explained the
beef between the actors with Ain't It
Cool News in 2006 saying Gear had
originally been cast as a lead in 1974
star Lords of Flatbush but since Gere
and Stallone clashed immediately drawing
filming gear was replaced by Perry King
Stallone recalls gear getting too rough
during fight rehearsals and spilling
greasy food all over Stallone's pants
sly claims to this day he seriously
dislikes me even thinks I'm the
individual responsible for the gerbil
rumor not true but that's the rumor just
relax me
you wanna talk book talk I'm a sucker
for great conversation Robert Downey jr.
versus Terrence Howard Howard isn't shy
about talking about his falling-out with
Iron Man co-star Robert Downey jr. sorry
buddy I'm just a different right now you
don't respect yourself so I know you
don't respect me in 2013 how it appeared
and watch what happens live and claim
that while the studio had initially
signed him to a three movie deal came to
me with the second and said look we will
pay you
1/8 of what we contractually had for you
because we think the second one will be
successful with or without you he went
on to blame Downey aka the former friend
whom it helped a book Iron Man in the
first place and I called my friend that
I helped get the first job and he didn't
call me back for three months three
years later the pair finally patched
things up and reunited at the 2016
wedding of director Brian Grazer Kevin
Smith versus Bruce Willis while Smith
and Willis have no issues acting
together and live free or die hard the
two hit the skids on the set of 2010's
cop-out in which Willis starred and
smith directed Smith had even taken a
massive pay cut in order to work with
Willis on the film but unfortunately
super stars sometimes come of super egos
it just went south
right away the whole thing went on Jack
Smith later described the cop-out
directing experience with Willis a
soul-crushing and credits Willis's
co-star Tracy Morgan with helping him
get through filming were it not for
Tracy I might have killed myself or
someone else in the making of that movie
he's just talking talking talking and
the whole time I'm just sayin that's
David Madison man in his twenty twelve
men were tough it Smith said that Willis
turns out to be the unhappiest most
bitter and meanest emo [ __ ] I've ever
met sir any job of held down and mind
you I've worked at Domino's Pizza ouch
julianna margulies versus Archie Panjabi
on the set of The Good Wife an ongoing
feud between stars julianna margulies
and Archie Panjabi caused tension for
years before panjabi left the show while
the characters were close friends the
actresses were not I don't have a
transformation you are a friend and you
like me the pair would not actually film
together for a whopping 51 episodes and
most on-screen communication between the
characters took place over the phone
when panjabi left the show she and Magoo
leas finally had a scene together but
yep it was also filmed separately with
some crafty post-production Betty Davis
versus Joan Crawford it was one of the
most famous Hollywood rivalries of all
time so much that effects even developed
a series centered on the feud these two
queens of the silver screen had it in
for each other as early as the 1930s
when Davis starred in the film dangerous
alongside Franchot tone Davis was soon
smitten with the actor but Crawford went
around marrying tone soon after the
movie wrapped production later Davis
famously remarked Crawford slept with
every male star at MGM except Lassie
the rivalry came to a fever pitch in the
1960s when Davis and Crawford co-starred
in whatever happened to Baby Jane when
only Davis was nominated for an Oscar
for her role in the film
Horford was livid
Crawford campaigned against Davis and
managed to steal the limelight for
herself when she accepted the Oscar on
behalf of winner and Bancroft who was
unable to attend the ceremony producer
William fire recalled Davis's reaction
at an Oscars afterparty
Davis filled a glass with scotch all the
way to the rim telling fire it was for
Crawford
when fryer told her that Crawford drank
vodka and not scotch
Davis replied I don't care what she
drinks this is going into a face thanks
for watching click the loop icon to
subscribe to our youtube channel plus
check out all this cool stuff we know
you'll love tea
[Music]